bonjour à tous vous êtes en forme ça
fait plaisir
je suis vraiment contente de partager ce
moment avec vous et j'aimerais commencer
en faisant connaissance avec vous alors
qui parmi vous c'est déjà posé la
question mais quel est le métier qui est
fait pour moi levet bien vous la main
que je vois un petit peu d'accord choix
que vous poser quelques questions sur
votre avenir professionnel
on va s'entendre qui parmi vous pourrez
répondre aujourd'hui à la question et
toi tu te bats ou dans dix ans c'est
plus difficile de se projeter
vous cherchez des réponses je comprends
bien selon une dernière un dernier
sondage de l'ifop
aujourd'hui c'est la moitié des français
qui estiment passés à côté de leur vie
ils ont envie de tout changer de tout
arrêter de partir de changer de vie un
français sur deux c'est énorme pour
garder votre voisin de droite pour
garder votre voisin de gauche c'est
potentiellement un de ces deux là mais
bon moi je suis pas vraiment surprise
par ça en fait je trouve ça compliqué de
construire une vie qui tourne tourne aux
aspirations personnelles
quand ni l'école ni les entreprises ne
nous permettent de développer notre
singularité au final est bien les
étudiants ils sont perdus dans leur
orientation
ils savent pas à qui s'adresser les
parents et les amis risquent
d'influencer les conseillers
d'orientation risque de nous mettre dans
des cases qui ne nous correspondent pas
et puis une fois qu'on est arrivé sur le
monde du travail
eh bien les places sont chères et
beaucoup arrivent et ne trouve pas de
sens ne trouve pas de sens il voit dans
leur travail
seulement un moyen de répondre à leurs
besoins vitaux et puis finalement c'est
une vraie contrainte
en fait on est en train de perdre nos
vies en essayant de les gagner
pour moi il ya vraiment un problème et
si vous remettiez vos dettes vous
quel suspense et si vous mettiez vos
inspirations personnelles et si vous
mettiez vos aspirations personnelles au
coeur de votre vie et si chacun de vous
et est capable de construire son avenir
en fonction de sa vocation à leur
vocation
vous n'allez pas entendre de la même
façon pour certains d'entre vous savent
être le métier que vous rêvez de faire
depuis tout petit businessman médecin
clown artistes bon pied et j'en passe
pour d'autres ça va être beaucoup plus
flou peut-être que vous avez
l'impression de ne pas avoir de vocation
et peut-être que ça vous paralyse dans
la construction de votre vie en fait la
vocation c'est un peu comme la quête du
grand amour
en fait on en entend beaucoup parler
mais on sait pas vraiment où chercher
alors ces gens là qui n'ont pas reçues
cette formule magique sur le berceau de
la vocation
il devrait quand même pouvoir s'épanouir
dans leur dans leur milieu
dans l'eure dans leurs études et dans
leur vie pour moi la vocation elle peut
avoir plusieurs vies plusieurs visages
elle peut vous tomber dessus
quand vous êtes enfant ou un peu plus
tard dans la vie et puis elle peut être
fidèle elle peut partir elle peut
revenir en tout cas pour moi une chose
est sûre c'est que votre vocation
vous pouvez aller la chercher de
différentes façons pour moi la vocation
c'est un idéal qu'on peut trouver au
carrefour de différents enjeux un enjeu
financier bien sûr que vous soyez
rémunérer un enjeu affectif que vous
aimiez ce que vous faites un enjeu lié
au talent que vous soyez doux et dans ce
que vous vous entreprenez et puis
finalement un enjeu sociétal que vous
répondiez à un besoin du monde qui n'est
pas satisfait ou peu satisfaits alors
vous avez beaucoup de critères toussaint
et puis finalement c'est rare les
personnes qui ont ce genre de vocation
mais combien vont la chercher
combien vont essayer de la cré et vous
en tout cas moi j'ai décidé d'essayer
parce que je fais la maligne avec mes
histoires de vocation
mais en fait j'en ai pas non plus et je
l'ait vraiment vécu comme une gelée
vraiment vécu comme un handicap
j'avais j'avais l'impression que que
tous les choix que je faisais elle avoir
un impact énorme et que les erreurs de
parcours était intolérable
pourtant c'est difficile de savoir quel
chemin prendre quand on sait pas où on
va
alors finalement et bah j'ai avancé j'ai
continué et puis j'ai découvert que et
bah finalement avoir une voix c'est bien
mais la construire c'est peut-être
encore mieux et moi eh bien j'ai trouver
du sens dans mon parcours en créant des
projets ce dessin pour moi il récapitule
bien l' escalade du projet finalement
quel que soit le projet que ce soit un
projet de vacances de couple un projet
artistique qu'il dure une semaine un
mois ou toute la vie il se fait par
étapes
on se met en route et pas à pas on
arrive à atteindre des sommets qu'on
pensait inaccessible initialement tous
les grandes tous les grands personnages
historiques qui sont passés par là
christophe colomb par exemple je pense
que s'il avait su que l'amérique était
sinon il aurait eu la flemme
alors au final le plus beau projet qu'on
puisse créer c'est celui de notre vie
alors je me suis en chemin pour créer
mon projet pour trouver ce projet
professionnel et pour aller chercher
cette vocation que je désirais temps
alors je vous présentais un peu les
différentes étapes par lesquelles je
passais pour aller la chercher ma
vocation d'abord faut oser prendre la
première marche
même quand on voit pas la suite de
l'escalier et ça c'est pas toujours
facile
moi ce problème j'ai été confronté au
moment de choisir mes études supérieures
alors que je savais absolument par à
quel métier je voulais être formés alors
je me suis dit à ce moment-là ce qui
peut nous aider c'est de nous dire bon
quelle est ma curiosité du moment sur
quoi je me pose des questions
et puis finalement et bah je me suis
rendu compte que je me posais des
questions sur cette crise financière qui
faisait rage dans la société et je
connaissais pas grand chose en russie
dit
allons en économie et gestion essayer de
comprendre et essayer de comprendre ce
phénomène pour essayer ensuite de
prendre part au mouvement à l'économie
nouvelle de demain
c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est peut-être
ce que vous avez ce à quoi vous avez
réfléchi en rentrant à l'union mais
manque de bol en fait je me suis rendu
compte que nos écoles ne savais
absolument pas à quoi allait ressembler
l'économie de demain non plus alors
c'est difficile de nous former à a2 a
créé le monde donnant avec les outils
d'hier
alors je me suis pas beaucoup et
épanouie dans mes études j'ai pas trouvé
ça assez concret à ses impacts en assez
centré sur l'humain
mais finalement j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé
un peu de sens puisque j'ai trouvé d une
vie associative une vie associative dans
laquelle j'ai pu m'armer de compétences
m'armer de confiance sur andreas furrer
et c'est une association caritative
j'ai pu y était allé pour être utile et
puis finalement je me suis fait avoir
parce que j'ai reçus au centuple tout ce
que j'avais eu envie de donner
et j'ai gagné beaucoup de choses qui
m'ont fait avancer c'est là que j'aurais
pu vraiment révéler mes talents pas
forcément dans mon école mais en faisant
j'ai lutté alors je me suis alors trouvé
une passion celle du développement des
autres et puis j'avais toujours et
bassett grande frustration que le
système éducatif ne nous aide pas à nous
développer
alors finalement j'ai décidé de
transformer cette passion et cette
indignation en action j'ai décidé de
bien de proposer des solutions dans le
cadre de stages ce qui peut aider dans
ces cas là c'est d'aller tester
différents types d'organisation je
travaillais aussi bien dans une start up
en france est un cabinet de conseil que
dans une ong au moyen-orient que dans
une ambassade aux états unis et ça m'a
aidé à avancer sur ce que j'aimais la
dent quoi là où j'étais bonne et puis là
où j'étais reconnu par les autres mais
ces trois clés pour découvrir quels sont
vos talents alors finalement ces
expériences elles m'ont conforté dans
l'idée que et bien j'étais vraiment
intéressés par ce domaine là mais
finalement
j'ai trouvé pas la marge de manoeuvre
que je souhaitais j'avais vraiment
besoin d'eux et bien de plus de plus et
d'avoir plus d'impact j'ai donc décidé
de sortir de ma zone de confort et de
créer mon propre projet d'entreprendre
au sein d'un projet qui me tenait à
coeur
je voulais créer une dynamique de
changement crée une dynamique de
changement mais du haut de mes 21 ans
était difficile c'est pas facile alors
j'ai décidé d'aller chercher ailleurs de
voir un petit peu tout ce qui pouvait se
passer
et puis j'ai trouvé une association qui
existait dans une école et qui essayait
de changer changer d'école de
l'intérieur qui donnait le pouvoir aux
étudiants qui les en power et qui leur
donnait des moyens concrets d'agir sur
la société
alors c'était pas encore très clair mais
en tout cas ça me parlait et là j'ai
commencé à rêver
j'ai commencé à voir grand j'ai commencé
à cultiver mon ambition
je me suis dit ce serait vraiment génial
que chaque école possède son association
noise et qu'elle puisse révéler aux
étudiants leur potentiel d'action et
qu'ils soient mobilisés au service d'un
changement de société plus sain en fait
et si c'était possible c'est tôt
possible et bien je le mettrai en oeuvre
au sein de ma propre université puis
grâce à cette expérience je pourrais
aider d'autres porteurs de projet à
créer leur propre association dans leur
école et on changerait ensemble le
système scolaire qui a assez défectueux
pour le moment alors rêver c'est bien
mais sans actions derrière ça va pas
très loin
donc je me suis au boulot et en trois
mois on a constitué une petite équipe et
on a on a créé cette association
notre rêve il nous a dépassés
au final en deux ans on était trois ans
étudiant dans six écoles qui faisait
bouger le monde
six écoles dont les avions d'ailleurs
vous êtes dans tous les bons plans
moeckli allemands ça nous a complètement
dépassés on a réussi à mobiliser les
étudiants de compétences différentes
avec des visions du monde différentes
qui avaient des opinions politiques
différentes mais autour de la même cause
celle d'aller vers une transformation
d'un monde un peu plus juste
et un peu plus souhaitable pour tous
alors j'ai à la sortie des études j'ai
souhaité sortir de depardieu souhaité
faire de cette passion en métier c'est
ce que j'ai fait je travaillais pour une
startup ce cas de fortes chances qu'il y
ait tous ces critères là et puis et puis
c'était une super expérience et j'ai
évolué je me suis rendu compte que même
si ce projet réunissait tous les
critères il m'avait fait aller dans une
autre direction
et puis j'avais changé à leur fille
nation finalement ma vocation
passer de la chercher et c'est d'aider
les autres à trouver la leur finalement
finalement finalement finalement ébats
ne pas avoir de vision claire sur sa
vocation
ça doit absolument pas être vécue comme
un handicap
c'est pas une fatalité c'est une
opportunité l'opportunité de créer son
propre parcours pas besoin d'avoir une
route toute tracée pour se mettre en
chemin
parce que finalement quand on se donne
les moyens eh bien le sens et la
vocation il arrive dans le chemin alors
ayez confiance en l'avenir
veillez surtout confiance en vous pour
créer les projets qui vous rendront
heureux parce que finalement ça vous
donnera l'opportunité d'être architecte
de votre vie d'être entrepreneur de
votre propre bonheur et surtout vous
pourrez changer la société à votre
échelle parce que finalement le plus
beau cadeau que vous puissiez faire
roman c'est d'aller vers la meilleure
version de vous-même construire une
société au sein de laquelle chacun
trouve sa place dans le respect de celle
des autres
c'est pour moi une condition
fondamentale au vivre ensemble agir
ensemble et grandir ensemble
merci beaucoup